right it's gonna be a conversation with
Joey Ito and Ethan Zuckerman on
journalism and innovation we're very
we're really looking forward to this and
we were very grateful actually that it
was time to early enough so Patriots
fans can leave actually and go back and
watch the Patriots Jets game tonight
anyways thank you very much oh one other
thing sorry I just want to explain hacks
hackers is a kind of an umbrella group
it's it's a group of journalists who are
interested in media and technologists
who are interested germs are journalists
interested in digital and technologists
interested in media so if you were
interested in joining you can find us in
the Internet
thank you very much and thanks for
bringing hacks and hackers here this is
a terrific institution we're really
happy to have it so we're really happy
to be hosting at the MIT Media Lab and
as Center for civic media to have this
conversation just bits of administrivia
if you hear sounds that sound like we're
cooking up terrifying chemicals in this
you're in basically our cafe space and
we're hitting the point of the day where
people desperately need cappuccino so
just try to roll with it
and and I say that not only for our
friends in the front row who are sort of
freaked out about the cappuccino sounds
but also we are streaming this event so
there's people beyond the numerous
people in this room so if you hear odd
sounds it is not in fact our secret
nuclear enrichment program going on in
the basement of the Media Lab it's
significantly more innocent and we're
here and this is a conversation between
me and Joey I'm Ethan this is Joey
Joey's tweeting some stuff I guess
between case just because there are
probably journalists here in case you
haven't been paying attention for the
last 40 minutes or thirty eight minutes
at five o'clock Twitter just tweeted
we've confidentially submitted an s-1 to
the sec for planned IPO this tweet does
not constitute an offer of any
securities for sale so there you go news
that's actually not a bad transition to
the first question I wanted to ask you
and by the way our structure for this is
I'm going to grill this guy for about
an hour we're going to open up the floor
you can grill him you can grill me
though I'm way less interesting than he
is and we'll have a conversation on
stage and then we'll have a conversation
with you guys and then I'm sure we'll
Peter off in all directions but I've
known you for a long time and I'm sort
of used to thinking of you as perhaps
first and foremost a Silicon Valley guy
with a strong social conscience with
things like Creative Commons but you've
done some really weird things in the
last couple of years you you came here
which suggests a really strong
commitment to the future of innovation
you've gotten under the board of two
massive US foundations the knight
Foundation the MacArthur Foundation
which suggests thinking about the world
of social change and then the one that
just truly baffled me was you go to the
board of the New York Times which
suggests that you see media fitting into
this somewhere so help me out how does
how does Silicon Valley
future of innovation news and civic
engagement how does that play together
so the since you kind of tied it to
biography I'll just start a little bit
there by the way for the record I was
interested in corruption before Leslie
went into corruption I the reason I met
Lessig was not a record show he was a
constitutional law professor I was in
Japan fighting the privacy fighting for
privacy related issue with the national
registry and I went to Lessig asking
advice on how to fix a broken democracy
which I thought Japan was and he said
well why don't you try this copyright
stuff it's actually really interesting
so I joined the board of crave Commons
and he went on and left me there and
went to cop corruption but anyway that
to me I've always had this question
about whether democracy was working
mainly because I lived in Japan which is
a pretty dysfunctional democracy of
comparatively speaking and and
you know and and a lot of the early
stuff that we were working on the social
media and I wrote that work with
everybody this thing about immersion
democracy is democracy gonna change with
social media and blogging so that was
always been sort of a theme and so what
I did my venture capital work investing
in six apart and technorati and stuff
that was when I thought that blogging
platforms and social media was gonna be
a really it still is but that that was
the way to do the impact and then as I
started to think about it and think more
broadly I realized that well we still
have these large institutions that do
news and that blogging by itself isn't
gonna fix everything and so that so I
think there was a period if you remember
when and I don't know which side you
were on the technological solar boy yeah
it was kind of when you know we were
declaring independence cyberspace was
independent and the end of the sovereign
nation and professional journalists be
damned we're gonna we were gonna take
over everything and it turns out we know
now that this is this is much more
complex and and that it also is it
sustaining me so so so now that I
realized it was complex I realized I had
to understand it better and that just
doing startups wasn't the way that we
were gonna fix this problem or to help
us get through this valley that seems
like it was showing up and so and and
one of the things that I realized that
when I was watching how blogs took off
and why they took off and this ties to
something that Nicholas Negroponte the
founder than me that I've talked about
when I was talking to him about the
Media Lab which is the early bloggers
whether it's Dave Winer
or Ben Amina or that there were people
who wanted to say something they were
creators people who were like
journalists but knew how to code and so
they built a platform that wasn't a big
IT company building a humongous content
management system for a bunch of people
who didn't want to be bothered by
technology right and and Nicholas's
version when he talks about the Media
Lab and what we what they're what we are
doing here is that where the the the the
design and the engineering and the
science and the art all come together so
he uses example of photography being a
very
interesting development process because
the photographers were also the people
working on the chemistry and the glass
and the mechanics so the photographers
were very involved in the evolution of
the camera and so it continues to be
very sort of artful in its in its
progress whereas television and and in
print there was a separation and there's
two reasons for the separation one is
the editorial has to be isolated from
the business otherwise it's going to be
tainted it's kind of like tenured
faculty right you've got to be
completely pure and so if you're not
bothered by the business side you don't
actually get your hands under the hood
and understand how the thing works you
don't worry about the technology won't
worry about the money so it's very
difficult for the people who were
actually using this stuff to innovate
because they don't understand how the
thing works and and I think that's true
with television it's true with a lot of
the other other even non news media
you've separated out right what I want
to I want to jump on that Nicholas
Negroponte analogy and that analogy that
certain types of creativity really move
forward when you have people who are
building the tech as well as building
the content right and so Nicholas argues
that you've had an explosion of
creativity and photography based on the
fact that your photographers are also
your chemists your your your optics guys
so on and so forth that you didn't
necessarily get in television you're
taking this a step further and you're
suggesting it's not just the tack it's
also the business right so you've got a
group here hacks and hackers who sort of
in the best sense wanna master both the
tech and the content but you seem to be
throwing this further challenge out
which is that the real innovation in
this is not just necessarily the tech
it's also the business model attached to
the type that's the element I think that
that that you learn in Silicon Valley
which is you can have the best utility
product in the world but without
distribution it goes nowhere I won't say
who but a faculty member here when I
first came said well I invented Twitter
30 years ago yeah but
yeah what does that mean it means yeah
we've got one-way signal visit but
technically inventing Twitter and
actually executing Twitter are
completely different things and so so I
think a lot of academia also thinks
about things in a you know in a sort of
functional way but there's a whole
business distribution sort of thing and
also a lot of it has to do with timing
and and and and to be impactful you have
to get that part and and I think that
that the sososo you're right I'm
throwing that and I don't know if it's
just entrepreneurship but it is an
understanding of business and also it's
an understanding of risk so you know I
would say that I put lawyers and
journalists in a similar category it's a
very interesting thing that I've noticed
this is that most of my best friends are
actually journalists or lawyers of some
sort but journalist and lawyers work
with risk all day long that's all they I
mean that's they're always talking about
and working with but it's other people's
risk right and lawyers and journalists
are so protected from personal risk that
they make the worst risk takers and it's
a very odd thing because it's kind of
like academics who like study business
but have never done it I find that it's
tricky because if you don't if you know
you don't know like a start-up
entrepreneur you fumble you learn you
know and and and you take risks by
accident and you learn from them
the problem with journalists I find and
lawyers is they understand risk really
well but they've never taken it before
so it's hard for them to take it so so I
find that you it's kind of like a
writer's block that you get in getting
journalists and lawyers to be
entrepreneurial I mean I'm sorry to
clump them together they're very
different but but I thought but I found
it and there but the ones that get over
that hump are often very successful so
let's let's explore what we mean by risk
right I mean there are aspects of being
a journalist that are extremely risky
you you take on a story and you know as
we're discovering you may have risks of
exposing your sources and causing grave
harm you always have the risk of whether
the story is going to pan out where
they're gonna get the information or not
it sounds to me like you're you're
talking about a different sort of
recipes so so let's go after two groups
of people that I know that you're
nervous about at the moment journalists
and tenured faculty so
two groups that I I know that you're
wondering about how do those communities
innovate and one argument I've heard
you've made is that in both cases there
may be this sort of blessing and the
curse of the firewall between the
business side of the industry and the
content side of the industry right so
there's the newspaper tradition at least
in in traditional news outlets not so
much in the new news outlets that you
have a publisher and you have an editor
and and never the twain shall meet or if
they do they meet under very certain
rules and in academic settings you have
the similar thing you have the the
university of the corporation but you
have the faculty who shouldn't be under
that pressure in one fashion or another
is that the sort of risk do we have to
get in and start breaking down that wall
to get the types of risk one is
financial risk but the other is the risk
of fundamentally changing the job so you
know I think I think it's it's it's so
so that when you're going through a
period of massive change you will like
for instance I was talking to some
people today about the social network
platforms you know so we have Twitter
going public but right now you have
these chat clients and like like in in
line and and what what is it like in
Asia particularly but you you're finding
that now they're becoming the primary
distribution channel for new stuff and
we're like the American version would be
candy crush Sega right saga but they're
but they're these content wise they're
suddenly going back to really really
rudimentary stuff but they've figured
out a way to use a social graph as the
thing and and what's what's amazing
though is that the company's just a few
generations ago that we're doing games I
mean I go into those details but but
they're recycling like every couple of
years right now and I think we're going
through a weird period where like if
we're we may go through some really
massive changes and there's maybe a lot
of casualties along the way so so it's a
like too many maybe too many metaphors
but like look at the icy marker here so
I'm gonna think about this but like look
at the form factor of our tablets yeah
so it's a small phone no tablet but like
the iPad Mini probably wouldn't have
happened if Samsung hadn't kind of made
a bet at this medium size tablet now I
don't think anybody would have been able
to predict what the right size is but
the Android Market let everything
flourish and a couple of them hit and
it's this weird multi it's like a multi
body movement problem you can't because
you can't you're not leading the market
they're not telling you what's going on
and it's this weird iterative process
where you get lots of casualties and a
lot of experimentation and my into that
I back to journalism this is why the
knight Foundation is really interesting
position to look at things from when I
look at the night news challenge and
look at all the crazy stuff that's
coming out there's two things one is I
think we have to experiment like crazy
because we haven't found what it is but
the added thing I would add to this
which increases the risk is that even if
we find it it may only be it for a few
years before the next it comes out so so
it's even a harder challenge because if
you're not too preneur in this space you
may become a myspace where you're like a
hit for a couple of years and you crash
so so it's a really tricky space that
requires a lot of risk-taking a lot of
innovation for people who have been
trained to be so good at what they do
that the cost to them of not doing it
anymore is actually pretty high and so
that may be another way of talking about
the risk so so let's unpack kind of a
last piece of that right so for people
who aren't necessarily getting all the
shorthand the the night news challenge
is as a project the knight Foundation's
been running for a couple of years now
each year they run several iterations of
a challenge it's a very low cost of
entry grant process so you can put in a
potential grant it's quite easy to put
it out there and they end up getting a
very wide range of ideas and they fund
quite a lot of them at a very high
failure rate so a lot of grants get made
a lot of them turn out not too
now now one way to look at this would be
to say if you really have a fertile
energetic market you would expect to
just be getting this out of the market
why does Knight have to see the market
but you also seem to be suggesting
something else is going on which is
maybe it's really hard constitutionally
in some fashion for journalists to be on
this innovative side of it is is the
market failing somehow in this is that
why Knight has to step in do journalists
need to step up where are you gonna get
that wealth of new ideas if as you're
saying you're gonna have a lot of
failure and some of those successes are
only going to happen for a very short
period of time I don't have an answer
that's why I'm exploring all different
ways to change do we does the New York
Times iterate does one of the challenges
create a new genre does social media
figure it out
or is it a combination and what's the
relationship between journalism and
civics which is but what you're working
on I mean to do it completely redefine
what what journalism and media is in its
relationship with democracy I mean
there's there's a lot of different ways
that this couldn't so this easiest way
is we replace journalism with something
that's very similar to what it is just
as the business model changes that's the
simple version the very complicated
version we end up with a public sphere
that's a combination of civics and
journalism and participation and a whole
bunch of other things and it happens in
a big blob but and in a bunch of
versions in between but anyway we should
talk about that but to answer your
question a little bit more and how does
it get fixed so this isn't making a
judgement but just looking historically
if you look at what one of the reasons
why Silicon Valley was successful or
another reason why blogging was
successful was massive unemployment so
this is kind of a joke but kind of true
that like Ben Amina had lost their jobs
in David Winer didn't have anything
better to do I mean a lot of the people
who wrote the software and a lot of the
people who wrote the blogs were
unemployed because we were in a wall
economically at the time that the blogs
were emerging so there was a lot of free
energy around high plug a lot less since
you hired me by the way yeah and then
and then if you look at startups in
Silicon Valley it really was when the
military
complex shutdown and you've had a lot of
really smart unemployed people who were
forced to do new things right so so I'm
not saying that unemployment is the
driver of everything but there
definitely needs to be a class of
entrepreneurial people that free up for
a certain category of innovation happen
now the difference though is in a
question is technical people who lose
their jobs can immediately start
building a technical thing one of the
problems I find with unemployed
journalists is that they haven't been
trained and don't understand the
technology or the business enough and
it's hard for them and I think this is
why these kinds of meet is important
because I think that the success cases
are going to be multiple people
co-founded things but but but I do think
that that the technical people
underestimate the complexity of
journalism and civics and the the
journalists tend to underestimate the
importance of understanding the
technology and I do think that it's
getting better though I mean I think
these kinds of meetings I look at but
you know but in but still in baby steps
I mean like we can probably fit in this
room all the people who would fit in
that category of understanding each
other but but I do think that that
creating that category of people and
then opening up a little bit of space
and then also having investors start
looking at that and so forth from
Knights perspective what we're doing is
just trying to make it more likely that
people will invest in these things
because I think that VCS hunt in packs
and if Jean WA is fashionable everybody
goes after it and and and and having
been a semi VC what you really worry
about is you invest in a company and
you're trying to raise more money and
nobody else will come in so there is a
manaat' just fashion it does doesn't
really make sense to be the only person
in a field because you end up with
having to fund everything so now I think
more more VCS are looking at this space
which i think is a good thing well so
let's talk about what constitutes this
space you you've put forward a really
interesting possible dichotomy right so
one version of this basically says
advertising doesn't work the way that it
used to circulation numbers are down
it's incredibly hard to
keep paying talented people to do work
that I we still think is very civically
important how do we find the alternative
business model and we've seen non profit
models and we've seen different
approaches to cross subsidy and we've
seen paper story and and none of it
seems to be working and overwhelming
fashion although you know the New York
Times paywall seems to be working a
little bit
you just put forth a much more radical
idea which is the idea that news changes
that civics changes that citizenship
that engagement changes and that some of
that change happens all at the same time
how do you build a company that rides on
that how do you innovate in that space
how do you both change news and civic
simultaneously yeah so so it's
complicated and and I don't think that I
don't think there is I don't think
anyone who says they know the answer I
don't think it's true I think we you
have a shifting landscape where the
civics is changing you have the
technology is changing so quickly right
it's not just going to mobile it's going
into all these different permutations
and it'd be interesting to see whether
the other players can stay in so what
what is what is news look like on a
mobile device everybody's thinking about
it so there's a lot of environmental
variables that are changing and then the
the fun so I I just talked about the
venture one there's also you know what
are the big media companies do there's a
convergence between print and video
right so CNN and New York Times are
competitors now and they would never
have seen that before
and then and then you have the role of
government funding and because obviously
the Civic side shows or like you look at
Al Jazeera and other things like that
and look so in the US but especially the
rest of the world trying to figure out
how a public broadcaster or government
funder all they theorize that the I mean
you say okay well maybe there should be
a bill that says the government will now
fund journalism and this is the way
we're gonna do it and then I don't think
that's gonna happen but but but there's
there's a there's so many different
things and I think that the the answer
is going to be that we have to try out
all of them we have to learn from the
mistakes and coordinate so that we are
learning from them but I don't I don't I
would place a lot of bets right now and
because you see like because there are
some interesting with all of its issues
I think that like Huffington Post is an
interesting little thing that is proving
something right and then you have the
you know and then there also the thing
that things that have been holding us
back
like the the cost and the legal cost of
protecting in the physical cost of
protecting journalists but then there's
like the idea of doing the independent
journalist fund and and there there are
things that I would not have thought of
that people are thinking of and so as we
stumble along I think that we're gonna
see a lot of stuffs but I think the
trick is just to it's being very
responsible we just need to keep moving
forward yeah you're being much more
optimistic than I expected from you I
was I was hoping for a slightly more
cynical Joey today but I I think one of
my questions and all this and so since
it's one of my questions I'll put it to
you on this is I would hope that some of
the entities that we want to innovate in
this space are big newspapers I would
hope that we want the New York Times The
Guardian and Boston Globe and so on and
so forth innovate and there's two things
that make me enormous ly nervous their
thing one is the Boston Globe a very
good newspaper purchased by the New York
Times for 1.1 billion recently sold for
70 million which sort of suggests that
there's a lot less money to play with in
this space there there had been so if
we're going broke it's really hard to
know how those entities innovate and
then the second piece of this is you are
someone who historically has been
extremely skeptical of innovation within
large institutions you're someone who
told me that once you have a company
that has a chief innovation officer you
know they're in real trouble because
they basically tried to put it off in
that box and you know they may not be
innovating how does the New York Times
innovate how does the Guardian innovate
how does CNN innovate how do these large
companies that are having fiscal
problems that are big bureaucracies but
have at the moment a critical civic role
how do they go after radical change I'm
not gonna speak
specifically about the New York Times
because I'm not supposed to but I will
say though thinking about it more
broadly about any institution
let's take well any institution that is
having fundamental existential or
business issues they actually have the
opportunity and the mandate to bet the
house on new stuff right because if
you're kind of doing okay a lot of your
shareholders are gonna say keep doing
whatever you're doing but if it's clear
that you need to think of something
really really drastic then you can place
big bets and I think that that's I think
like Apple did that before the iMac it
was a sinking ship and this is a famous
story but like Steve Jobs could have cut
costs but he innovated his way out of it
and that's a successor that there's a
different version of the story but but
the idea is when you're sinking you have
two ways to go you can bet the house on
something and go all-in or you can try
to become smaller and smaller and
smaller until you disappear if you're
trying to become smaller and smaller and
smaller and hold on I wouldn't be
interested in being part of that model
because like Japan is doing that with a
lot of its companies they just focus on
cost-cutting and you can cost cut
yourself until you're you basically
disappear and that's just that's
literally sinking with the ship I I
think that there are newspaper companies
and people buying these paper companies
who believe that with the right bet we
can turn these around we don't know
exactly what that bet is I mean the
paywall was a little bit there are other
bets that we're working on but I think
that that all the smart newspapers are
realizing that this is a really
important period and so all of our let's
talk more generally Media Lab all of our
media partners really want to really
come to the table it feels like on the
news and journal on the side and so so I
think it's an interesting opportunity to
one get the companies to collaborate
with each other I mean just short of
antitrust and then but then to really
try to swing for the fences because it's
kind of it we near the end of the game
right so so I think it's exciting
actually for
to see large companies placing big bets
so I like the optimism around the
sinking ship requires a big bet I like
the idea that you have simultaneous
changes in news and in civics at the
same time I feel like we're talking at
the Warren Buffett level here right I
feel like we're talking about and that's
why I went out and bought 40 small town
newspapers because I think we're gonna
be able to turn this around many of the
people that we have here in the audience
are either journalists for publications
that are trying to figure out how to
keep their heads about what there's a
wake going on on the sixth floor for the
late great Boston Phoenix we time this
really badly so you know Boston's you
know sort of other really interesting
and intelligent newspaper yes I'm
dissing The Herald it you know died
recently and you know we're sort of
mourning their death upstairs and there
were journalists involved with papers
worried about what they're gonna go at
the same time we have individual geeks
individual hackers sort of looking for
that innovation bring this down to the
individual level what do you do within
an organization when you feel like there
needs to be radical shift and revolution
how do you make that space how do you
find that space to innovate within those
sorts of been a big orgs so I think if
you look at this let's just take blog
because even though that didn't save the
world like many of us thought it might
it was a tremendous amount of impact
that came from a relatively small number
of people that initially kind of figured
it out and it was like it was kind of an
obvious idea once they started doing it
but it was completely non-obvious to
people who were in the content
management industry they thought content
management system should be you know big
and expensive and workflow and lots of
people and but it took a few people who
just sort of looked at it differently
and so to me what's interesting also is
all of us founding teams are either
individuals a very small number of
people so so I do think that the this is
generally true about innovating in big
organizations but I think it's it's a
it's a small
number of people who understand enough
about what needs to get done that go off
and just do it and there are there was
this is a completely other random
example but when I was working at info
sake we were working with Disney and and
there was a there's a couple of
engineers who went off on the weekends
and created this service called Star
wave which was kind of also kind of a
content management thing and oddly with
there's a despite Disney's reputation
these were employees of Disney who have
built a sign business but Disney was
good enough to go and then buy it and
use it and it was this really kind of
weekend skunkworks project by people who
were employed it says this is how we
should really do it not like that and
then they just do it in it and I think
the that's still the the that it's the
model I mean I guess what I'm saying is
like then this comes from the Silicon
Valley thing do the cost of innovation
is so low that with two or so agile
engineers and and maybe like really two
or three kind of people you can make the
next blogging system or the next Twitter
or the next whatever and so I think the
trick is to keep its small keep it on
the side and not try to do it
institutionally and then when it happens
to be smart enough to embrace it and I
don't think that those people need to
quit the day job necessarily to try it
and I think that the large institutions
should allow innovation on the edges but
I think that that's the most likely
space from which it's gonna go so I I I
want a call [ __ ] on that actually
because you and I were talking the other
day about how innovation actually seems
to be happening and in a company like
Google and it's not 20% time it's not
someone who should have found a way to
sort of go off and doing it these start
becoming very very big shifts it's very
hard to go off and carve it out and
maybe there's there's the happy story of
folks coming out of interesting it
mostly seems to be about acquisition it
mostly seems to be someone going out
starting something fairly new and then
getting swallowed into this is that
where media needs to go do you need to
have folks in the Boston Globe
skunkworks create something that the
globe can't see how to make it work but
then go out there and sell it to the
Guardian
or sell it you know I think if you look
I mean Google over sells that 20% time
but there are innovations that have come
out of it and it's it's it's it's not
new stuff and that story that I always
like is I think it was um 1925 or so
1930 but it was it was before the Great
Depression 3m was a sandpaper company
and this guy who was an engineer sales
guy saw them sending cars to paint but
they were using two-tone painting so
they were using some butchers paper and
adhesive tape and every time they rip it
off it would ruin the paint job so he
said well we understand adhesives we
understand paper I'm gonna invent
masking tape and the boss said no you're
not and he did anyway and the boss came
in and saw him working on it and let him
anyway and so then he what didn't have
the authority so he wrote $99 checks and
bill and went into manufacturing and
then masking tape turns out to then
evolved into scotch tape that actually
saves 3m through the depression because
people start taping things together
instead of buying new stuff but but
that's but that that was innovation on
the edges it was innovation that was
anti-authority and I think that that's a
kind but but but it was important that
that engineer knew the strengths of the
company that it was adhesives and paper
but to turn a sandpaper company into a
scotch tape company was a was an
important iteration and I think that
there's a version of that that could
happen possibly in a newsroom with the
right person is it is it the hackathon I
mean the this has become the the latest
trend right so we're gonna do the same
thing every day and then we're gonna
take 48 hours and and and we're gonna
hack it is that is that helpful in a big
organization to create the space for it
is it sort of the worst kind of lip
service where you basically say we don't
want you to make the rest of the time
here's that here's the 48 hours where
you can do it how for people who are
sitting here instead of saying okay I'm
up for it I want to figure out how we
how we turned sandpaper into masking
tape I'm up for that
what's the way that a large institution
whether it's the New York Times or
whether it's someone else how does that
space gets it let's go back to three M
so 3m figured out that they needed
innovation on the edges so they did I
think it was fifteen percent time so
actually the Google wasn't the first to
do it and I think that's where I have to
check on it so I'm almost positive
that's where the post it came from and
so I think 3m was able very early to
institutionalize that and do it fairly
well so I wouldn't be too skeptical
about and again you don't need them to
happen every year in volume you only
need the masking tape and the post it
every once in a while every couple of
years to get you out into the next thing
and so I don't I think that if all the
newspapers did something like that and
if in the next three years one thing hit
but that was the thing that saved the
newspaper then it would have been worth
it and and in - and 15% of everyone's
time is a is definitely worth the
investment if the probability of the
masking tape goes out so I wouldn't but
I would say also the possibility of it
coming from the outside is high and
they've even higher so the the doing
that is because part of this was talking
about how do you change the decision
from the inside I think that you need to
do that and the hackathons and all
that's important but I think that the
probability that comes out from left
field so there's two there's two left
fields versions there's look at the kind
of Silicon Valley startup in America
thing but there's you know Egypt or some
other weird country where we don't have
an incumbent big media thing where them
like or you know you look like it was it
in Norway the BG news portal guys you
know that website and I mean and there
there's weird things going on all over
the world where you see successes people
making money doing things and so I think
part of this may also not happen in our
ecosystem so I want to open this up in
just one moment but before we sort of
get there I think the question that I'm
most nervous about at the end of this is
what if it turns out that the masking
tape basically involves giving up on the
Civic side of it what if the success and
the way to sort of innovate going
it basically says yes the Boston Globe
now with four pages of news and 60 page
in the sports and you know 120 pages of
lifestyle tips what what if most of
those likely models don't recognize that
sort of dual bottom line that need for
the civic bottom line and that need for
the investigative work the informative
work the the way of holding
authoritative power has anyone done that
balance between new product while
holding on to that sort of critical
responsibilities at the same time and I
something must be wrong with me because
I'm gonna be optimistic again for you
but I think that the purely financially
driven single bottom-line model of not
having any social cause is is kind of a
blip I think that that like if you look
at the history of corporations like in
the early days you really actually had
you couldn't set up a company unless you
had a charter we're gonna build this
windmill and it's gonna help the
community so we're gonna sell shares and
we're gonna build it now we got the
windmill I mean that's how it started
we're gonna Christianize the East Indies
and take it over like finance used to be
very and it was funny because you just
flip it around the foundations were the
opposite you have a pile of money you
don't know what to do that was you know
so so it's we're gonna set but anyway I
I think that the trend that's I think
the whole philanthropy thing is going
through massive change right now I think
that the idea that first you create a
tax shelter for big money coming out you
know create an institution that sits on
it and then does good
that's MacArthur night oh that that's
gonna shift and the future philanthropy
is gonna be really interesting because
what you're finding with you know what
you have the services and the Bill
Gates's of the world a the people who
are still alive and doing it I think
they're all one I mean like meteor is
trying to do their thing school's trying
to do their thing I mean people are
realizing that the way to have impact
with their money
and the we haven't figured that out yet
either so so I think that there's a huge
pile of money that's looking for a way
to be good and they haven't figured it
out and a lot of people are becoming
skeptical that charity is the right way
to do it and so when that gets figured
out somehow there is money that will
flow into it in a very different style
than Wall Street money flows and and
again this will be an in and and again
we're this is you know we're trying to
figure this out on the foundation side
you know so so to me that I'm worried
about in the short term really losing
good journalism to pure commercial
things but then I start to think about
the the nature of institutions and how
they get funded is changing and possibly
there's an answer to how to fund
journalism in the future of philanthropy
and foundations as well I don't know but
maybe yeah so I mean this sort of
summarized a couple of the ideas here
that that struck me I'm struck by this
idea that the single bottom line might
be a moment in time and and that that
actually really resonates with media
companies media companies historically
were classic double bottom line
companies and they were measured at
least as much of their civic impact as
they were they were measured on their
financial impact in it it was sort of
the the turning newspaper companies into
securities in the 80s and 90s that in
many ways may have led into sort of
where we are right now so that strikes
me as very promising I wanted to remind
people of what I thought was maybe the
most radical idea that you'd put out
tonight which was this idea that this
may not be about shifting a business
model but it may be about a much larger
change in civics what it means to be a
citizen what it means to be a
participant what you need from the news
which suggests a much more difficult
path towards innovation of one fashion
or another and I would say getting back
to the originally original sort of
confusing business metaphor I was trying
to
is it's a moving target because the
behavior patterns the consumption
patterns and the cognitive models of the
people is changing very quickly so every
generation has a very very different
behavior pattern so if you build
something for a particular generation as
it ages everything's changing and so
when when you have and the problem is
the companies are not going to change
fast enough I don't think to keep up
with how quickly people's behavior is
changing and so and I think behavior is
fundamental to civics and and I don't
think we can like the tablets I don't
you can predict it and so that's the
really really hard thing and that's why
I think small things doing iteration
rather than sort of grand theories about
how it's gonna work is our more likely
to succeed good know a lot to work with
let's open it up we got a mic over here
feel free to step on over to it I'm not
gonna take directly out of the audience
because we are live casting and so it's
hard for me just to call but feel free
to queue up and we'll go in the order
hey thanks so much I just went to a
intro to journalism class here at MIT
and the professor asked us who reads
newspapers here and not a single person
in a 23 person class where their hand
including me so you guys talked a lot
about the responsibility of companies
that companies need to change companies
need to adapt but it sounds like the
people you're serving the constituents
the people buying these papers are as
Ethan you put it more interested in
sports the news more than ever before
and I'm just wondering it is a dying
battle because I see businesses as a way
to serve the community and if the
computing he's not asking for
information then it seems like a cycle
that's just gonna die please give me
hope well so first good what's your name
identify hi I'm Elliot thanks Elliot so
I think it might be a bit of a false
comparison Elliot right so newspapers of
delivery service and and in some ways
we're using newspapers as sort of
shorthand for professional journalism
and instead of the idea that someone is
paid to have enough time to go out find
the facts behind something
put a layer of interpretation on it and
give it to us in one fashion or another
and I'm gonna make the argument that the
23 people aren't devoid of news although
if you're telling me the 23 MIT students
taking an intro journalism class and I'm
assuming this is set new concise are
completely void of news then we're in a
much more dangerous situation a which is
it do you were they news free or were
they or were they newspaper free um you
you actually asked we read anything
online do we read any articles and most
of these students ran at MIT so we're
doing our repeat shots and things like
that but there isn't an interest they
didn't see much interest in finding
things now maybe and I don't know maybe
you guys would say things like watching
MTV and hearing something on the side or
whatever people do I hang out in the
Media Lab and people tell me things like
you guys but um I so I I don't know that
I'm gonna give you hope because that
that's really depressing but but let me
let me give you a twist on it and and
we're doing a chunk of research right
now on sort of media coverage of the
California ballot propositions in 2012
and we're trying to track how they were
covered online and offline and like we
don't have a bunch of data because the
answer is they just weren't covered that
much and so at a certain point you have
to sort of go well it's not new media
it's not old media there's just not a
lot of conversation about this and so
you can either throw up your hands
instead of go well geez maybe we just
don't do civics anymore or maybe the
answer is we do it in some other places
and so I run into a lot of people who
are college students who are not
directly related in civics and politics
but might be deeply immersed in some of
the debates about feminism and misogyny
online that have been sort of raging in
the last week with people sort of
weighing in on misogyny and tech culture
instead of where all of that is going
and so for me one of the questions is is
has just the space shifted are we
looking in the wrong space is it just
about looking for engagement with the
political process is it about looking
for engagement with social issues with
other forms of issues and is that and
happening in other spaces but I I do
think that's terribly depressing and I
would hope that the response would be
well if none of you read news why the
hell you're taking this course you know
I I have to think that that there's some
sort of exaggeration going on in there
but but maybe it is really a profound
shift of sort of where that's happening
to any hope at all you're in a much
better mood than I am tonight I know
that was a shock to me too but but you
know then I reflect on myself I didn't
really care about current events when I
was in college that much either I think
that it grew on me as I started hanging
out in the real world so I don't know
I'm not that optimistic but maybe maybe
you kids will learn ok I'm weird because
I read the New York Times since
elementary school
not a good sample but you know I also
think back to the journalism before
advertising when you had you know Thomas
Jefferson writing his stories frankly
whether it's worse now but or we you
know if trying to reduce a very complex
system simple point what probably trying
to solve
keeping the newspaper artifacts alive is
this a side issue it's sort of like the
railroads trying to apply the business
model to sidewalks and the real issue is
accommodation we've become so good
financially at funny parts we've lost
the ability to wholes we expect little
magical devices to solve climate change
without solving the whole so the real
question I think the previous you know
question for the right point is how do
we get and informed I was gonna say
electorate but it's really informed
population I mean the idea that has to
be electorate is going too far
but is it part of Education how do we
fund things that larger than the next
sports event
there's the readers side which I'm gonna
let
you can talk about that for me when I
think about so so this I guess I can
talk say but I I one of my first New
York Times board meetings they sent me
home with all the Pulitzer Prize
nominations from the Boston Globe in the
New York Times was a packet like this
and I read every single article it's
kind of like the best of right and you
see article after article where
journalists have spent a year in the
middle of tremendous risk to uncover
this corruption that's killing somebody
or this company that did this thing and
and bloggers don't have the freedom to
do that they don't have the legal
support they don't have the military
support they don't have the funding or
the training to do this now mcCluggage
do really well like with the Dan Rather
thing whether that was a good thing or
not and that bloggers are good at
digging up certain types of facts
there's crowd swings a bunch of stuff
but there's a certain category of
investigative journalism that keeps
power in check right whether that's the
NSA or the federal government or or big
companies that right now we don't have
anything that replaces that category of
professional journalism and and that may
not be the article that all everybody
reads but that has a tremendously
important public function of keeping
these people on their toes these people
I mean people in power on their toes so
so that's that I feel is a function that
is important that is part of the diplom
democracy system which is different than
the engagement of the readers and the
civics part I don't know I think you
think you've thought about that part
more than me well I mean the the the
Smorgasburg that is a conversation with
you it lets me sort of pick and choose
and so the the idea that I enjoyed from
this evening was this idea of not fixing
business models but fixing something
much broader and I I find myself sort of
wondering whether what we actually need
to fix is citizenship to one extent or
another I'm getting a lot out of Michael
should syns work and I've gone back to a
book that he wrote now 14 years ago
called the good citizen where he
basically says that so much of what we
think about in journalism is this sort
of model of we get informed we read
everything very carefully and then we go
and vote and that's our civic duty and
he basically says
that's [ __ ] like who actually reads
the 400 page voters guide and then goes
and votes on all the propositions it
absolutely doesn't happen and that
because that sort of progressive you're
a model of citizenship doesn't work
doesn't also mean that you sort of throw
out all the other aspects of the
democracy and he basically says we've
moved into this rights discourse we use
the courts we use other ways to sort of
get through citizenship I think we're
moving to a place where attention is one
of the most important things that we
sort of work on this and I think
citizens try to figure out how they use
in shape attention this is what happens
when someone finds an issue that they
care about and they share it with all of
their Facebook friends and maybe that's
how are our friends you know friends are
said finding out about it and I think
that professional news organizations who
still incredibly powerful actors within
that space whether it's putting the
resources in themselves to sort of find
malfeasance and draw attention to it or
whether it's a much more complex process
where you have someone like a Snowden
working with a Greenwald who's you know
somewhere between journalists and an
amateur and has sort of an amateur who's
gone pro and then the platform that
comes off of something like The Guardian
or The Washington Post but I'm starting
to wonder if if what's really going on
here is just a shift in how we do civics
and that the elections in some ways are
getting less important than how we're
driving attention in one sort of
direction or another and if we do have
this sort of big seismic shift is this
where we go this still doesn't get us
out of the problem of needing to have
journalists who can do really high
quality verification who can gather
large audiences but it also does mean
that that landscape is going to shift
and that it's not just going to be The
Times or sort of other organizations
it's going to be new entities that also
sort of command those massive audiences
at the same time Greenwald thing and
that it's kind of a I think there are
signs of different ways to do this sort
of thing but just if you think about the
sheer volume of work we still need to do
we just don't have that replacement yet
I think we're in there's it's a dip
there's there's a lot of stuff going on
that I
I'm very impressed by so so I'm not I
don't want to diss the amateurs because
I think that's that's a big part of it
and then on the collective you talk
about this a lot when you talk about
Tunisia and the relationship between
al-jazeera Facebook and was no op right
that triangle right now is really
important and I think that part of the
solution of where we're going maybe
looking at these ecosystems where the
mainstream media the the sort of social
media or amateur media and the activists
kind of work together whether it's
inside here square or wherever we've
worked at mostly in toppling things but
we're now trying to experiment in
building things but but I think there's
a there's a there there and and and that
I think that experimentation may be
happening in a more interesting way
outside of America where you you you you
you have more more hardened topple thing
yeah my name's Laura Miko I'm a
journalist and entrepreneur and a
Berkman affiliate my question is in
regards to leadership and it's because
we discussed risk and innovation and
journalists on the ground and hackers on
the ground my question for you Joey is
whether we have the leadership in
organizations in media right now to
really bring these changes that maybe we
see on the ground to fruition and make
them happen and perhaps if we don't have
a leadership that we need where we might
look for models to find it and I just
want to put some contacts for not
everyone who knows who Laura is Laura is
is one of the cofounders of an amazing
journalism project called homicide watch
that really sort of redefined what we
expect out of coverage of homicide first
in the city of DC and instead of going
on elsewhere but it's also a project
that's had a very hard time finding
support ultimately went out to
kickstarter got great community support
to keep going but you know may have
suffered some of those real questions of
who's going to have the leadership to
talk about leadership in the media
institutions or just generally or both
frankly whether we might find leadership
on the outside that is going to rise in
the coming years or whether there's the
vision for leadership inside of
organizations now that we are going to
wait and see Germany yeah so I kind of
go back and forth on leadership I
sometimes feel like leadership is
overrated and I see a lot of really
important movements where the leader is
emergent that just happens to be the
person in the middle but that you know
whether it's I mean so like a really
good question if you asked Wikipedians
is is the founder Jimmy Wales what was
his role and what was the level of the
importance of that being Jimmy Jimmy
himself will thoughtfully think about
the question so so sometimes I wonder
whether it's leadership or it's the kind
of the right timing in the right context
and then the person being a catalyst but
I don't think you can lead a bunch of
people who don't want to go basically
the leader is the one who's jumps in
front of the parade you know and so so
in a sense when I think about it and
even at the media I mean yes I'm the
director of media I'm do people do what
I tell them to do no you know so so so
what's my role here I have a certain
role of creating certain allowing
certain types of things to happen but I
can't force anything and so so I so I
guess this is a roundabout way of saying
that I think leadership is important but
I think it's more important to find the
timing and the context and the right
Network and being in the right place at
the right time then somebody kind of
figuring it out and and and and the the
other reason I would like I'm gonna go
off but I think the reason East Coast
venture capital failed and West Coast
was successful and nothing against them
cuz they're my friends but like like EV
Williams or Zuckerberg they're not
impressive people right like when you
meet them if a venture capitals meet
some East Coast venture capitalists who
are into big companies they wanted
people that look like they could sell
lots of enterprise software impressive
people who were business suits who could
be articulate the people who are
building these disruptive companies the
larry's and the Serge's they're not
traditional leaders they're people who
know
to code who are very good at product who
can see the timing but they'd also lead
in a very very different way and so I
think that the successful media
landscapes that we're gonna see we're
gonna see a different category of
leadership and and if you look at open
source projects and their leaders they
tend to have a very different kind of
personality whether you take a linus
torvalds you probably don't know who
runs pearl right now or Python or Apache
I mean and they're very they're much
more kind of community organizers and
they are sort of leader leaders and so I
think I don't know I'm not sure if I'm
answering your question I think that the
the big media companies too a lot of it
is about the so there's another saying
that I hear a lot where you always have
incentive to [ __ ] your boss so by
the time you get to the top of the
organization all you have is [ __ ]
left and so in an Oregon in a company
where you kind of they're doing the same
thing repeating it doesn't really matter
if the boss doesn't know what's going on
because the thing kind of runs itself
but when you're trying to figure out
what's going on the leader is not
necessarily the one who should be making
any important decisions they're the ones
that make rooms so that the people who
know what they're doing can do what they
should do and so it's I think it right
now it's a the best leaders are the ones
who enable things to happen rather than
cause them themselves so Laura I'm gonna
I'm gonna answer the question
differently and I'm gonna I'm gonna
translate somewhat from Joey I don't
know what I'm translating from Joey to
but I'm gonna translate from Joey one of
the reasons I think people get excited
and probably overexcited about Silicon
Valley and innovation is that people
like you who start something radical and
different that gets a lot of attention a
lot of support then end up being the
head of these companies and that's not
really how media companies have been
shaping things over time and you don't
get to be the editor-in-chief of the
Boston Globe
by starting homicide watch and it's
actually kind of interesting to think
about whether things would look better
whether they would look worse how they
would look different if people who had
interesting media startups suddenly
found themselves sort of vaulting into
power in one fashion or another
I'm very interested in this new West
Coast venture capital fund that's only
funding guys who look exactly like Mark
Zuckerberg I thought that was very very
promising but it is it is an interesting
question of what it would take for
someone like you who really is doing
something very innovative to find
herself should have been that very
senior position I think that's an
interesting question trigger I rode
Ruger Davis from the center for civic
media we've been talking about this kind
of short cycle short sort of
entrepreneurial cycle as being central
to innovation where there are lots of
casualties lots of disruption magic
capitalist entrepreneurs are rewarded
for you know taking on that risk but
that also obviously comes at a cost to
the user the user is also disrupted
which in in some categories is great
because I have all this choice of safe
food products but what about areas of
life in which users perhaps don't want
so much change I would probably put
government in that category maybe even
your sort of major media diet some
people would even say you know there
bookmarking service they don't want it
to change very often I guess my question
was are those areas where innovation
does need to come from within the
company because you know the New York
Times can try or The Guardian can try
something innovative but if that breaks
at least I know the Guardian will still
be there tomorrow when I want to I
I think the way I would so there's two
pieces to this this is some things are
better to not to change from the users
perspective there's another version of
the side of this which is if you have a
tremendous brand you have sort of a
responsibility to deliver a reliable
service and not jeopardize that brand
equity for irresponsible risk and and I
think the answer part of this is again
that the innovation happens on the edges
with the users who want because there
are certain users who try any
bookmarking service every day and don't
care and they might after a while
discover one that they all like and
maybe they get older and decide they're
gonna stick to it if you look at for
instance it's very interesting I don't
know if they have them in the Unites
States but you have the electrical
organs so if you if you look at the the
the evolution of the synthesizer at some
point along the way the electric organ
forked off and stayed the same and
synthesizers kept moving for a while and
it's it's very interesting to see where
you have these little communities where
they still like like BlackBerry users
still like the keyboard and and and
other people are moving on so it's so
the the interface part I think you have
you have to look at it as clusters and
what you want to do is you want to
experiment on the edges and with
government I think you you go to a place
where they have no government and so
something is better than nothing so they
really don't have anything to lose to
try something innovative and new whereas
in the United States the cost of redoing
something is really high and so I think
what you do is not in addition to the
cost of innovation for the innovator
there's a cost of innovation to the user
and it's a combination of personality
and the environment that they're in
now if something's super successful and
it tracks this is what big IT companies
or service companies like Microsoft and
the googles will buy those companies and
say okay we need you know a photo
service we need a mobile thing and they
buy it and they integrate it and so
that's the way they can eliminate some
of that risk is to have it being tested
be tested on the outside bring it in
explain to their users and and and
manage it but but I think that right now
that the risk-taking it's very difficult
to do it on the core product of a of a
big domain III
with you on that but I guess I'll just
add one but but like the Kindle they did
it in Palo Alto away from home base and
there's a skunkworks model or the
off-brand model which big companies can
fund and it's it's a hybrid I think
between the venture model Chris hi there
Chris Peterson of the Center for civic
media I'm two quick questions
Joey you talked a lot about failing fast
and a lot of things will fail and if you
will succeed and we'll know from there
but I'd be curious in listening to more
about how you recognize a success and
how you recognize a failure and this
gets to Ethan's I think last dystopian
question of whether success or failure
in this space means capital revenue
whether it means some civic thing that
we're trying to measure in some other
way and how we can separate the two when
it's none obvious and the second thing
is you mentioned the Media Lab professor
who posted 30 years ago of having
invented Twitter you mentioned that a
lot of this success whatever it looks
like is timing but if it's timing I'm
wondering how much you think of it is
actually planning and executable and how
much of it is kind of random contingency
interpreted after the fact as vision and
timing and if it's mostly random
contingency it seems to me that while
the systemic incentive is to have as
many people trying new things and
failing the incentive of any one
individual actor or whether it's
institution or entrepreneur is not to do
that because that's actually entirely
outside their control so how do you
change or strengthen those incentives
other than saying well if you don't
you're all out of a job so you might as
well so it's a complicated question but
let me try to publish but I'm actually
gonna make him diagram it on the back
but first of all that the the unemployed
thing that I mentioned that actually is
a very interesting driver because like I
was saying if you have nothing to lose
you might as well take risk so so that's
the easiest way is to have a lot of
unemployed smart people who may even
have money and then it's even better but
absent that you know I think that a
couple there's a couple of things
that that III think I destroyed ten
companies before I even was able to make
one that actually made money and I think
that failing is a really really
important element of learning and I
think most people don't get the first
one right and then even if you get it
right it's very hard to get the second
one right I mean if serial entrepreneurs
are really rare but but you have to
train and so for me you know you just
assume that that your first couple are
just gonna fail and you try to learn
okay now I learned accounting on this
one now I learned that I need to do this
and I need to do so so to me it's a
learning exercise rather than oh my god
I'm afraid to fail and that's why
failing fast is important but I will say
that like I often say compass over maps
like so if you use this example in other
places but like if you talked to the
look YouTube 2005 was a dating site with
video the default was I am male looking
for anyone between 18 and 35 upload
video right so so they pivoted though
and they were Flickr with video and then
they then latched on to MySpace so they
there but they always knew they want to
be a big humungous video site but their
failures were in that particular
implementation but they kept along the
path now sometimes you should just
terminate the long-term vision as well
just because it's just a dead end but a
lot of times the when we say failure
it's that particular iteration that's
failing and to pivot instead of saying
well we spent 200 million dollars and
created a whole group to make this video
dating site let's try it for another
couple years that's what I mean by
failing fast as if it's not working
pivot right now and it's a lot easier
when you have a smaller number of people
because you have written less code and
invested less money so that the the the
assets that you flushed down the toilet
when you pivot are a lot smaller with a
smaller group and the it's at least like
like Shawn Fanning when I was hanging
out with him Warren's in California like
every single weekend he would show me
another site that he'd written over the
weekend they all were usually
unreleasable because they were you know
here's this cool interface I made for
Pirate Bay that gets data from Amazon
and then lets you search it and
downloads and plays it no but but he
would hack something out every single
weekend that was really really
interesting and that's how he kept his
brain going and he would get his
reaction
his friends then occasionally you find
one that was actually legal and then he
would lunch it yeah but but but but but
but but it's like a muscle you know to
get to do this and it's really really
hard to do it at the beginning so that's
why I think that it's not
I wouldn't think about it as one big
risk but a whole bunch of I mean you're
taking a risk being here for a couple of
years I mean what you learn with Ethan
may have end up being completely
irrelevant for your future you may end
up becoming something else right and so
so it depends on what because it's just
time if it's just you and a couple of
friends hacking yes you get at your
stipend here so but but so that
everything that you do is a risk doing
nothing is a risk too so I think that
when people say fake failure it's it's
to me failure that sorry I'm gonna
because failure I think he's a people
have the wrong image of what people said
mean when they say failure so for me I
was like when somebody used to say
that's hot I wouldn't believe them I
touch it miss oh it's hot I get ok I got
it
so that's failure failure is that it was
hot but then that becomes information so
for me failures are the creation of
facts if you theorized it you don't do
it you end up with a theory but not a
fact if you try it and you fail you know
you were wrong right and so then you
learn it better so certain people learn
better through failure than they do
through theory and that you know so the
ludicrously complicated second part of
the question said if we don't know
whether success or failure is a matter
of timing or external factors or so on
and so forth if we don't know that the
faculty member you know who claims to
have created Twitter might have failed
because the world wasn't ready for his
genius at that point how do you then
take that leap if you sort of know that
failure may be actually sort of out of
your hands it may not actually be your
fault when you end up failing I would
hypothesize or something I don't know
for sure but I would say that there's a
there's there's a certain level of
intuition that you get after being in
the market and failing in different ways
of getting when the timing is right and
then there's a there's definitely kind
of almost like a motor skill
in knowing when to iterate and knowing
when to pivot and knowing how much
energy to put into stuff and and you get
that through doing you don't get that
through studying it that's why I was
just and sometimes you get lucky on the
first one in you go but sometimes you
fail a couple times but you do get
better at it
I guess that's I guess that's my point
from my experience is every single
company that I started I got better at
it every time the first couple were just
terrible you know I was I was stupid but
I was trainable and after a while I got
good at it and so so I think that that's
what I would say and I think that the
timing in the context part well the risk
is always there you can greatly minimize
the risk by doing two things one is
having a wide network because if the
good venture capitalist and the good
entrepreneurs know what everybody else
that is doing anything is doing and so
you know what's going on you know like I
know like people send me emails oh hey
have you seen this new social thing in
in Korea or did you see that line just
past four hundred million users and in
all these different places and things
going on that information helps you
judge and when you're new you don't have
access to that information that's
another thing that you can develop that
helps you mitigate the timing and the
competition problem publish a weekly
that looks at what's happening at the
local colleges and universities about
energy and other things and since about
eight nineteen eighty nine I'm going to
all of these open events at Harvard MIT
and other colleges and universities
around a lot of it about journalism and
at the same time I got online and what
I've noticed is that journalism is not a
business it's a subset of advertising at
least in the United States and that in
the transformation of the media
landscape the publishers of newspapers
and magazines still haven't understood
that it's a community conversation
because journalism is not really a
business there's a kind of chip on their
shoulders and an elitism I feel for
instance David Gregory suggesting that
perhaps Greenwald should be arrested as
a spy we're gonna go across so I would
like you to address those ideas
advertising as the overall arching
business model for journalism which is
just a lost leader and the elitism or
the lack of a communitarian idea within
the professional journalistic community
the good news on this is that if you're
worried about journalism being an
extension of advertising you know you
don't have to worry for that much longer
that that models dying and it's dying
very very quickly and to the extent that
professional journalism is going to sort
of continue in this fashion I don't
think it's gonna be able to survive in a
serious fashion around that same
journalistic model my I haven't done my
backstory onstage here because there's a
conversation with Joey but my first
company the only company that I've had
any meaningful success with went into
business selling web banner ads at
seventy five seventy five dollars for a
thousand of them and anyone who's bought
advertising on the web knows you know
just how ludicrous that is and we're now
you know four banner ads you might be
talking some tiny fraction of a penny
and so that market rationalized over the
course of twenty years by a factor of
more than a thousand and it wasn't just
my ludicrous little company sort of
going from what at that point was a very
reasonable print CPM down to this sort
of absurd low web CPM which is the
reality of today it was the entire
advertising industry discovering that
they'd created such massive oversupply
that the bottom completely fell out of
that market so
yes there's enormous problems of
newspapers not recognizing themselves as
community actors and I think in fairness
there's a great deal of insecurity
because institutions that have been
important community actors for a long
time are now going through this very
radical shift and the answer may be that
you end up in a place where the only way
to support a Boston Globe is through
something much closer to an NPR type
membership where people become Boston
Globe members and actually feel like
they have some ownership over it and
feel like they have part of that
community so they're jointly coming
together and finding some way to sort of
support that so I I think that's coming
and and and I think sort of stripping
away maybe some of the angry part of
that question I actually think you may
be pointing towards the future George I
don't know if that's something you want
to run at all no I think you're right I
think they have to say carefully but the
large publicly traded company that you
are on the border but I basically just
predicted will become a membership
organization and it's a great mimin
article right and I think on membership
models which I I liked but um but but
but I do think that there definitely is
a sort of amateur versus professional
thing that seems to be melting over time
but still exists and I think that
different institutions have different
levels of it and I'll just leave it at
that I would I decide I'm just saying I
identify that as still an issue that I
think and then there's also the curation
versus original work thing and I think
different publications have different
levels of comfort in acknowledging
different types of sources I think there
really I guess one point I will make is
what a comp are who was the director
general Val Jazeera when he was here he
made a really great point which was they
would not have used these amateur
stringers and the social media if they
had a choice but at the time of Arab
Spring in many cases they didn't have a
choice
they use them and then they turned out
to be awesome and then
they became friends and then he hired
them and so so it was out of necessity
that they they broke that professional
journalism sort of bar at some level and
and I think that that it was it was
interesting and to hear him sort of tell
it that it wasn't it was kind of
accident yeah and then I think there's
been a lot of that transformation and a
lot of institutions because I think we
got time for two more but let's try to
go pop my name is drew Hans I'm with a
project called track 180 I'm gonna dress
two things one is the Civic side and
getting community involvement and the
other one is the business model but
instead of the backend business model
and I look towards the customer so what
we looked at doing is figuring out how
to get people more involved with an
issue that's happening around the world
so what we would do is we would take say
an issue that's happening in my Ammar
towards girls in schools so what we
would do is we would take multiple
perspectives around it and actually
direct people directly to the people
that are doing something about it so
once they got engaged they could feel
empowered to do something so the way
that we came up with the multiple
perspectives was we looked at some of
the pew data that said basically the
news consumer is unhappy and some of
that data from the 2011 is stories are
inaccurate 66% stories tend to favor one
side 77% and are often influenced at 80%
those are pretty staggering numbers so
what we found is if we looked at how to
address that issue which I'm gonna ask
him I think that's the problem in Jeff's
purchase of the Washington Post was
saying that specifically what he's going
to look at what is the customer the
reader going to do so I think the
ability for the the shift of opening up
to what the consumer is actually
concerned about bias whatnot and then
connecting them directly to the issue to
make a difference I think it's gonna be
a very powerful piece and in a lot of
the roles that we've come across is
people were hesitant to actually connect
that bridge and so I think that's an
old-school model and I think for me
personally I see a movie I'm engaged I'm
upset I'm pissed off I'm sad I want to
do something about it now give me some
choices so that I can help this group or
that group which is the democracy of
information so I think my what
sharing is what we've seen in the data
and our project and we're getting a lot
of favor on it so on a big commercial
level is the big commercial side willing
to address that dissatisfaction and be
are they willing to cross that bridge of
saying these are your options so I'm
gonna grab this one if I may so I I'm
really interested in people who are
trying to link reporting an action
because I I have the same sense that you
do I think a lot of what's not working
well for news organizations is reporting
stories that no one feels like there's
anything they can do about they're not
motivated to act on so I I'm interested
in projects like yours I'm following
closely projects like shout about and
such I would say there's a couple of
places where there's obvious problems
and obvious tensions right so the first
is that I think if you go into an
existing journalistic organization and
you sort of say I want you to write
stories that end up with and here are
things you could do about it everyone
immediately you know puts up and says
that's advocacy journalism we don't do
that and there are some reasons to have
that response when Fox News goes out and
essentially says you know what's wrong
with America it's two men you know too
much Taxation too much regulation and
and by the way if you'd like to do
something about it there's this amazing
group that's doing a rally in your city
this weekend you could be there it's
really hard to sort of know how to take
seriously an outlet that has sort of put
together a package of reportage and then
sort of a specific action to the man the
flip side is on a lot of these other
situations I can report to you a
horrific situation in Somalia and if I
don't give you anything that you can
sort of end up doing on that you may not
being sort of missed more disempowered
at the end so finding some solution to
the is there something between the
journalism of pure detachment informed
citizen model and the the advocacy
journalism model that freaks everybody
out is there a middle ground
I think the second is this question of I
think there's an enormous gap between
finding and the Pew
that people think that news is biased
and projecting a giant audience of
people who want to read news and go out
and get engaged my guess is that that
may be a subset of the audience and I
think it's probably a small subset of
the audience I don't know that we can
expect every reader to sort of pick up
the newspaper and then figure out how to
engage engage in any time and again by
newspaper I mean sort of any sort of
news piece of it
so I absolutely think it's a piece of
the equation but I'm curious sort of
whether those hyper engaged readers who
are following an issue because they're
passionate about making change around
that issue whether that can be the
backbone of a model for journalism going
forward but there's a lot in there that
I think is really promising of really
rewarding what we found in our
click-throughs are that whether or not
they actually give to the organization
or do anything then finding out what
that organization is doing is actually
adding information to create what
they're learning about I'd like to take
these two questions it's really quick
like one after another and we'll let
Joey respond and then we got a we got a
wrap up okay
just quickly going to Joey's earlier
point about how valuable information is
coming through the network for assessing
you know what kind of decisions you make
in the future where innovation is going
I'm wondering if you think there's ways
to provide economic valuations for
journalism and for information that are
a little bit more complex than you know
just clicks or that really provide a
more holistic picture to that to the
actual value and even the economic value
of good information good journalism and
you are I'm Philip Guerin new to MIT at
the Sloan School awesome and then one
more quick question hi my name is
Jonathan Barron ville I'm a software
developer and my question is in the area
of software and innovation so like what
would you say like somebody like a young
software engineer like me that has like
ideas like world-changing ideas like
things you know would change a lot of
things though
how the world works and stuff like that
and you would like to commit to them
full-time or something but you don't
really see how you could do that you
know without you know being a but
basically you want to be able to commit
to it full-time right and I know like
their stuff out there like Kickstarter
we could create a great campaign but
that will only support you for a certain
amount of time so like how would you say
somebody approached that where like you
want to really change something and you
have the idea and you can't actually do
it but you don't you just want to be
able to commit to it
so two questions alternative metrics for
news value what's news worth and what do
you do when you know you have
world-changing ideas and you need to
find ways to support them get out there
they both relate with money what's
interesting so you use the word value
but value is a really difficult word and
some people I've talked to recently who
are very smart don't believe there is
such a thing as value because its value
to who and the problem when you try to
link financial value you know it's like
Ethan may not want to read the news
about the this but this person they want
even to read the news and so it's kind
of like it's very difficult to take a
thing like news and create an absolute
value for it I think it really depends
on who doesn't benefit and is that
person capable of paying for that and
then it turns into you on the one hand
you may have is in advertising as a
version of that it's some sort of
information about something that wants
to be transmitted so it's got energy
behind it and the consumer the problem
is and we I don't go long on this but
like this is a sports thing I mean most
of the people will want stuff that's not
necessarily I'm gonna make them better
at being civic citizens they want junk
food and sports and all this other stuff
that's the buy side this the pushing
side if you take reporters as a proxy
for more a bigger thing which would be
say the common good
then who funds that and this starts to
tie to the other question which is if
there's something that's very important
that and this is this is I think
journalism kind of falls in that
category as does a lot of things that
are good for your health but the person
that you want to deliver it to
that doesn't have the money or doesn't
he want want it then who pays for it
right and it can be government it can be
foundations it could be a private
interest that happens to have an
alignment with the common good or it
could go against the common good and you
may find it easier to get funding for a
newspaper that's very heavily leaning in
a political direction so so I think it's
it's a really tricky thing to ask about
because also you're making a judgement
also when you say I have a great idea a
great idea for who write it's like I
have a great idea to make a very racist
site to go after all those bad people
that I hate so much or I mean like you
know somebody I read an article that
said New York Times is exactly 56
percent left or something like that
but look what does that mean right and
so so it's it's so it's really tricky I
mean now I'm just talking kind of from a
Content perspective now I think there
are great ideas for business models and
structural stuff and and that ought to
be funded and we won't go into all the
detail here but but that's one of the
things that night foundations trying to
figure out so we invest in for profits
we give grants through nonprofits we do
little grants to do big grants so in the
journalism space I mean I would say if
you think it's a great idea I'd love for
you to pitch it tonight I mean this is
kind of what we do and now if it's a
for-profit we are starting to create a
network of other investors that we bring
into the deals but we're trying to
that's a problem that we're trying to
focus on so I want to offer maybe a
piece of practical information on that
which is absolutely look for
opportunities put the idea out there
look for ways that people can fund it
but one of the best things to do is to
figure out a group of people who are
really willing to listen to the idea and
willing to critique it and willing to
get on board with you when it's a really
great idea and are willing to help you
sort of shape it and push it and
sometimes that means finding an
institution that is trying to bring on
smart young people and so to find a way
to change and I would say some of the
better news organizations actually
probably fit that bill you can do this
outside you can do this inside part of
that process of sort of building up the
skill set that you always been talking
about throughout is that process of sort
of iterating and failing
getting there and reducing your cost of
failure particularly early on in your
career may actually be a really
interesting way to cope on it very
surreal thing I'm getting text messages
from people in the New York Times
newsroom who are following New York
Times fridge who are tweeting about this
and so it's this very surreal thing
where high professional journalists its
III do think that this coupling of I
mean the a lot of people are paying
attention to this right now and I think
that were the the I IND know that you
know everybody wants this to get figured
out and I think everybody realizes what
the issues are at some level and I do
think that it's we're in a moment where
the the the antagonism between the
amateurs and the professionals is died
down and turn much more collaborative
then I've felt it I mean it's continuing
the process but I think it's a really
important time right now where you have
the hackers and the Boston Globe coming
together you have newsroom reporters in
the New York Times watching this and
commenting on it and it and it and and
everybody's you know I think it's it's
that everybody's a little bit kind of
needs to do something right now and it's
very different than it was I'd say 18
five years ago on that hopeful note many
thanks to Joey many thanks to the Media
Lab many thanks to hacks and hackers
thanks for coming
you